Sam a great finish for you with the
white pieces against Andrew Tang you
wanted really badly to win this game and
in fact you did so in extraordinary
fashion but it all started in the
opening after D3 He started thinking for
30 minutes and he decided to play that
move D5 let's take a look at that and
tell us your reaction after the move
D5 yeah um he generally doesn't Play The
Marshall but I did see that he tries it
sometimes in critical games so I didn't
really expect this line I decided to
play D3 to avoid all the theoretical
lines and you know he went for the pawn
sack anyway with D5 uh initially I
thought okay this is ridiculous I'm just
going to take the pawn but he he had an
idea he wanted to get rid of my Bishop
uh I me if you play uh H3 instead of
D3
uh uh Bishop B7 D3 D5 e takes D5 Knight
takes D5 Knight takes E5 Knight D4 this
is like one of the critical positions
and I think he wanted this after H3 so
that was his kind of concept after D3 as
well that makesense I me the main
problem for him is the bishop is kind of
stuck on SE and I have a lot of tactical
resources as you saw yes yes you did and
this was actually a very nice one after
Knight takes B3 a takes B4 a critical
moment at this point yeah I spent a lot
of time here because uh both Knight
takes A1 and Knight D4 are very
important if Knight D4 I have a
beautiful move Knight takes B5 mhm mhm
mhm uh once again this tactic Works he
probably has to take on B4 when I'm I'm
a pretty much a healthy Pawn yes and he
took on A1 we initially looked at this
position and we were like okay this is
over right you just pick up the Knight
on A1 at the right moment and then this
is over but it wasn't that easy to get
to that Knight because of this A5 idea
yet you found this move to E4 that's
yeah exactly that's why I spent so much
time on this AES before because I I
initially I thought okay he can't take
on A1 then I start realizing this Pawn
on B4 he can just go A5 and protect his
Knight yeah uh so here I spent some time
and I'm I really like this move Rook E4
because if I can get my Rook to
C5 uh I have a really good really good
structure um so if I start with Rook E5
very important he plays Rook
E8 and I can't play Rook C5 because of
Knight takes C2 back rank problems MH
yes so uh the reason I started with Rook
e four was uh one of one of the reasons
is if he plays A5 which is the natural
movement position B takes A5 Rook takes
A5 I have B4 and the bishop goes to B2
and his Knight's he has to protect his
Knight with two Rooks and I'm attacking
his king um so I think he had to play
Rook A8 instead of
A5 sorry Rook E8 E8 okay Rook E8 yeah
yeah and now Bishop E3 he amazingly can
still go A5 it's really
annoying and now if he take he takes
with a queen yeah exactly yeah I was
going to play Rook D4 and keep and H4
and just play this position I still
think White's better but it's very
complicated uh yeah with the knight1 so
when he chose Queen C6 I was very happy
because I managed to get this clamp with
the Rook on
C5 very nice uh and now my Rook protects
C2 which is like one of the good things
about this
position yeah he can never get his out
anymore yeah Rook a was an interesting
practical try because he wants take on
B2 and if I play Bishop C3 he has a nice
trick with Knight B3
ooh very nice yes you can still survive
Bishop takes G7 but OB I can still
survive yes and uh also if in after
Knight B3 Rook G5 I thought this win's
on the spot initially he has Knight D4
uh which was kind of a could be a cold
shower the Knight came from A1 to D4
yeah so I went for Bishop C1 exactly
yeah so I went for Bishop C1 B4 Queen H5
and yeah he did this I I had no time but
I managed to calculate until Knight E5
uh I think this wins because after Queen
E4 I have Rook takes C7 oh very nice
okay Rook takes C7 Rook f8 Queen G5 and
his pie are just out of the game I'm
just mating him
yes there's no way to defend same thing
after same thing after Queen B3 uh Rook
takes
C7 just one detail that's important uh
he doesn't have Rook A7 which is kind of
saving the game because I takeen there's
M on
E8 yeah yeah beautiful so he has to give
he has to give the Knight and then
White's just easily winning y very
nicely calculated uh definitely a
satisfying way to finish a tournament in
such a complex battle with a good
victory congratulations uh Sam we'll see
you in the next tournament absolutely
thank you Carissa re